herzlich willkommen zu einer deutschland
am freitag
und wir starten die sendung mit einem
corona kompakt zu gast ist gleich der
virologe professor plachta und so sieht
es aktuell in deutschland aus nachdem
bekannt wurde welche bundesländer
schulen und kitas schließen
die stadt halle hat gestern als erste
die reißleine gezogen
seit heute morgen sind alle schulen
kitas und horte der stadt an der saale
geschlossen
während in bayern heute morgen noch die
erste unterrichtsstunde in den schulen
lief trat der ministerpräsident in aller
frühe vor die kameras und verkündete das
unterrichts ende für alle nach der
rücksprache auch jetzt noch mal mit
allen ministerien und führt mich
folgendes an
erstens ab kommenden montag werden die
schulen und kindertagesstätten
kindergärten geschlossen
das ganze gilt jetzt vorläufig bis zum
ende der osterferien lehrer schulen
schaffen neue probleme vor allem für die
betroffenen familien organisieren wie
wir das alles hinbekommen wenn wir sind
noch alles erklären mit meinem mann auch
gleich mit ein paar eltern von der
krippe auch ob wir da drei kinder
zusammen dann betreuen
das virus wirkt weiter in 24 stunden hat
sich die zahl der infizierten um 690
erhöht ein weiterer infizierter ist
verstorben
seit mitternacht dürfen deutsche nicht
mehr nach tschechien reisen kontrollen
wie die auf der a17 zwischen dresden und
prag im erzgebirge können deutsche nur
noch passieren wenn sie einen festen
wohnsitz im nachbarland nachweisen
können nur tschechische bürger die in
deutschland arbeiten dürfen weiterhin
die grenze in beide richtungen
überqueren
ein problem auch für die
deutsch-tschechischen skigebiete im
erzgebirge wie hier bei oberwiesenthal
wir haben ja am fichtelberg gemeinsam
mit dem technischen sie gebiet eine in
die skiregion das heißt
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr der mir im
moment natürlich unterbrechen müssen
archivfoto schon eingestellt aufgrund
der grenzschließung die pisten fahren
müssen sich entscheiden für tschechien
oder deutschland
ich finde das ist nicht in ordnung
lieber aufpassen dass die leute ihn
nicht kommentieren
seit gestern nachmittag gibt es
kontrollen der deutschen bundespolizei
an der grenze zu frankreich
so wie hier im saarland wir befragen die
reisenden ob sie sich beispielsweise
unwohl fühlen ob sie symptome zeigen wie
fieber oder und husten und sollte das
der fall sein informieren werde die
zuständigen gesundheitsämter die ja dann
in der pflicht sind
innerhalb von wenigen stunden hat das
saarland gestern von bundesinnenminister
das go für diese aktion bekommen wir
machen temporär kontrollen speziell was
die französischen gäste angeht wir haben
ein fiebermesser mehrfach erfahren wir
befragen die leute weil dadurch das sind
es die franzosen die tests angestellt
haben haben wir ja die situation zu
verzeichnen dass jeden tag 18 tausend
pendler kommen teilweise ungetestet das
risiko ist uns zu groß
die kontrollen sollen im laufe des
wochenendes weiter verstärkt werden ab
montag stellt das saarland auch den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr nach
frankreich komplett ein
die betriebsamkeit reduziert sich
allerorten auch auf der reeperbahn in st
pauli nur wenige touristen und passanten
verirren sich in den zeiten von corona
auf den kiez winter sei sowieso wert
herunter corona virus also leute sind
schlaue bleiben zu hause besser so ich
wurde auch zu hause bleiben arbeiten
müsste an den taxiständen dagegen viele
wagen ohne fahrgäste denn die sind
mangelware
wir wissen nicht was wir machen sollen
aber das sieht nicht nur schön aus wenn
fahrgäste hatten über wochen nur über
kollege redet nur also normale thema ist
aus auch die urlauber wende ich kam
gerade vom flughafen und die fahrgäste
die fragen so vor wie sieht mit dem
krone aus das persönliche verhalten
ändert sich weil den meisten das virus
gefühlt immer näher rückt tagtäglich
damit rechnen dass ich zum beispiel ich
bin im außendienst tätig das ich denn
meine berufliche tätigkeit einstellen
muss nur noch bürotätigkeit von zu hause
aus machen kann die kundin besucher
fallen flach paar einkäufe getätigt so
die grundnahrungsmittel
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass man
wirklich gehamstert hat aber man sich in
den geschäften umgesehen hat das war
doch schon vieles vergriffen
ich finde es richtig dass fußballspiele
abgesagt werden ich das richtig dass
theaterstücke und opa stücke und was
weiß ich nicht alles abgesagt werden
aber ich achte
seit dem ausbruch vermehrt darauf dass
ich meine hände wasche ausführlich
gründlich sie regelmäßig desinfizieren
dass ich leuten nicht zu nahe komme und
auch das händeschütteln beispielsweise
vermeiden
unklar ist auch wie es mit den tafeln
weiter geht also der
lebensmittelversorgung von bedürftigen
weil viele menschen die supermarkt
regale leer kaufen denken weniger an die
tafeln wie hier in marburg
bei diesen lebensmitteln ist die
spendenbereitschaft um 90 prozent
gesunken insgesamt wird hier ein viertel
weniger gespendet als sonst jetzt wird
das natürlich für die eine oder andere
gerade für die großfamilien ein bisschen
brisant ist prekär weil natürlich kann
man sich nicht komplett von den
lebensmitteln die wir ausgeben unsere
kunden kunden ernähren das ist sozusagen
ein zusatz für die familien und dieser
zusatzbericht jetzt bedauerlicherweise
sehr stark ein
vielleicht hat ja der eine oder andere
im zuge der korona epidemie zu viele
lebensmittel werbung hat die tafeln
würden sich freuen wenn einiges davon
bei ihnen landet eine region in
aufregung die eigentlich von der ruhe
lebt nur noch am staffelsee im
voralpenland die touristen bleiben weg
absagen die die existenz bedrohen
selbst die große hotels mit
internationalem ruf unserer umsätze sind
zwischen 50 und 80 prozent teilweise 90
prozent hier im land eingebrochen
und wir sehen uns einer völlig neuen
situation gegenüber auf die wir so
schnell gar nicht reagieren können
weltweit haben die menschen im kampf
gegen das corona virus aufgenommen wenn
es schon nicht gestoppt werden kann so
soll doch seine ausbreitung wenigstens
verlangsamt werden hier in iran werden
ganze straßenzüge desinfiziert denn das
virus wütet in diesem hochrisikoland
besonders heftig mehrere ranghohe
politiker und regierungsbeamte sind
seinetwegen bereits gestorben
in china dem von dem virus am schwersten
betroffenen land begnügt man sich nicht
mit herkömmlichen desinfektions methoden
ultraviolettstrahlung soll öffentliche
verkehrsmittel wieder sicher machen
der vorteil der uv methode ist dass sie
viel effektiver ist und schneller geht
deshalb ist sie auch billiger 99,9
prozent aller viren werden so abgetötet
der kampf gegen das carola virus wird
auch in der wissenschafts front geführt
ein impfstoff ist bereits in arbeit
seit mehreren wochen schon werden
impfstoffe in verschiedene impfstoffe im
labor gebastelt das geht relativ schnell
und tatsächlich sind auch schon die
ersten studien an menschen haben jetzt
so angefangen das hat es noch nie
gegeben also wir kennen das virus
eigentlich erst seit dezember und sind
jetzt schon im märz dabei neue
impfstoffe zu testen
allerdings wird ein passender impfstoff
nicht vor nächstem jahr zur verfügung
stehen er impfstoffe sind ja substanzen
die wir gesunden menschen geben wir
müssen wirklich sehr sehr rigoros
getestet werden also wir müssen erstmal
nachdem wir die gebaut haben schauen im
tiermodell meistens sind die sicher
machen die das was sie machen sollen
können die antikörper oder andere
immunantworten induzieren
und dann muss das ja im menschen
getestet werden ist mit kleineren
menschengruppen gesunden sind die sicher
diese impfstoffe machen die keine
nebenwirkungen machen wir was sie sollen
induzieren sie antikörper und dann geht
die entwicklung weiter und das dauert
das da kann man ganz wenig abkürzen an
diesem prozess hoffnungsvolle signale
also aus der wissenschaft nicht nur beim
impfstoff sondern auch beim
testverfahren ein test aus der schweiz
schafft jetzt in dreieinhalb stunden
klarheit ob eine infektion mit dem
corona virus vorliegt oder nicht hängt
bei mir im studio ist professor wurde
plachta ist viola an der
universitätsmedizin mainz viele
bundesländer haben schon oder schließen
alle kitas und grundschulen was bringen
diese schließung weil sie das hilft man
hat immerhin
sehr viele regionen oder sehr viele
bereiche wo eben menschen in dem fall
kinder und jugendliche sehr eng zusammen
kommen natürlich dadurch blockiert und
damit natürlich die übertragung in
diesen bereichen blockiert hat man geht
ungefähr davon aus dass ungefähr 20
prozent der versammlungen tatsächlich im
lande tatsächlich schulen und kitas
betreffen
das ist natürlich dann auch ein problem
aber das sind natürlich auch nicht
solche großen menschenmengen wir denken
gymnasium vielleicht 1000 schülern ist
natürlich eine andere situation
jetzt wird oft gesagt kleinkinder oder
kinder können den virus in sich tragen
ohne dass er sich äußert und sollen
deswegen eben zum beispiel die
großeltern nicht mehr besuchen
ja das ist sicherlich sicherlich
sinnvoll im augenblick war eben diese
älteren personen gruppen besonders
gefährdet sind und natürlich kinder
gerne mit den großeltern kuscheln
beziehungsweise eben umgekehrt auch und
da kann natürlich sehr leicht so erreger
übertragen werden und die menschen eben
über 70 75 80 sind besonders gefährdet
durch diese infektion und das ist auch
wirklich so dass die kinder diesen virus
eben übertragen können komplett ohne
letzte änderung 10
das ist offensichtlich möglich kinder
erkranken kaum oder nicht wirklich sehr
stark das heißt dass es durchaus möglich
dass das so gut geht sozusagen und das
dann tatsächlich ein virus obwohl das
kind gesund ist auf den europa
übertragen werden kann
ok bei uns werden die meisten
veranstaltungen über 1000 personen
abgesagt in den niederlanden sind es
beispielsweise nur 100 was hatten sie
dafür sinnvoll ist grundsätzlich
natürlich immer abzuwägen ist diese
veranstaltung unbedingt notwendig oder
kann man darauf verzichten
und es sollte halt alles das was
irgendwie verzichtbar ist im augenblick
tatsächlich abgesagt werden aber man
kann nicht alles absagen sonst haben wir
an situationen eben wie im augenblick
auch in italien was man nicht haben
möchte alles klar
dann fielen dank professor platter für
den moment sie sind ja noch mal bei uns
da sie bleiben noch bei uns und die neu
eingerichteten testzentren sind jetzt
heiß begehrt wer vom hausarzt die
anweisung erhalten hat kann sich an
diesen speziellen stationen testen
lassen auch für unsere kamerateam
herrschen dann natürlich höchste
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
atemschutzmaske eine schutzbrille und
natürlich handschuhe nicht nur das
personal ist hier in voller schutzmontur
sondern auch wir müssen diese subkultur
anziehen um hier drehen zu dürfen
sicherheit geht vor und so beginnt der
dienst für die helfer auch an diesem
morgen mit dem anziehen der
schutzkleidung die müssen alle tragen
die später in direkten kontakt mit
möglichen infizierten kommen werden
marcel eger rettungssanitäter bei den
maltesern koordiniert hier alles hat er
angst sich selbst anzustecken
also hier sind wir natürlich mehr
geschützt als man strauß im
rettungsdienst oder die abwehr in der
arztpraxis und da ist dann die gefahr
natürlich viel geringer als in den
normalen arbeitsleben kurz nach 10
während die schlange hinter der
teststation schon jetzt immer länger
wird startet vorne die erste
untersuchung an diesem morgen der catan
ist arzt eigentlich im ruhestand er
macht heute die abstriche um
herauszufinden ob die patienten
tatsächlich mit dem neuartigen corona
virus infiziert sind
und im sommer cdu abstriche machen und
wenn in ihrem garten finden war
verbrachten bau dieser rentner und seine
frau sind als nächstes dran
ihr enkel war beim skifahren in
österreich wurde dann krank einen test
hat ergeben er hat sich mit corona
infiziert jetzt ist er in häuslicher
quarantäne
[Musik]
zum corona test der qatar nimmt auch bei
ihnen einen abstrich wie bei allen aus
dem auto heraus und kein
ansteckungsrisiko für andere menschen
einzugehen
bis zu 300 patienten testen sie hier pro
tag
als nächstes steht der test bei dieser
familie an sie wollen wie viele andere
patienten hier nicht erkannt werden
haben angst stigmatisiert zu werden
sie waren in frankreich in einem gebiet
das inzwischen als corona risikogebiet
gilt wir waren vor eineinhalb wochen im
elsass da war noch nicht bekannt dass
das ein risikogebiet ist und aus dem
grund sind wir hier zur vorsorge weil
mein sohn und meine frau jetzt husten
haben die schlange vor der teststation
wird unterdessen immer länger an die 80
fahrzeuge stehen zeitweise gleichzeitig
auf dem platz bis zu vier stunden
wartezeit seit der eröffnung am montag
reist der zustrom nicht ab jetzt nach
einer stunde haben wir mehr autos als
die letzten tage hier stehen und wir
sind am montag schon überrannt worden
von den menschen so viel andrang haben
wir nicht erwartet
und das obwohl ausschließlich die kommen
dürfen die im landkreis esslingen wohnen
und von einem arzt telefonisch hierher
geschickt werden sowie ihrem sitz und
ihre familie die jetzt gleich untersucht
werden
nur wer sowie ihren nachweislich mit
einem corona infizierten kontakt hatte
oder aus einem krone risikogebiete nach
deutschland kommt wird hier getestet
zusätzliche voraussetzungen die menschen
müssen corona symptome zeigen im zwei
bis drei minuten takt fahren die
patienten hier vor abstriche machen
daten aufnehmen darauf achten dass
nichts durcheinander geht bei dieser
großen anzahl an menschen dazu das ganze
in diesem schutzanzügen es drückt im
gesicht die brille ist nicht wirklich
bequem aber eben kratzen geht nicht und
der overall schränkt die
bewegungsfreiheit zusätzlicher die
schutzkleidung auch für arzthelferin
isabel meister hahn ungewohnt und
unbequem
sie kümmert sich um die registrierung
der patienten und das richtige aufheben
der kleber dessen probe auch zu den
richtigen patienten zugeordnet wird das
ist halt wichtig dass man da nicht alle
derzeit einfach falsch reagiert das
stimmt ja hinterher alles nicht mehr um
die mittagszeit müssen isabel meister
hahn und ihre kollegen sich um ein
junges paar kümmern
auch das will nicht erkannt werden wir
waren im ski urlaub in südtirol und
wussten dass es einen positiven fall
dort gibt wir haben uns letzte woche
testen lassen weil wir beide
erkältungssymptome hatten und waren dann
auch positiv das heißt wir waren somit
unter den ersten infizierten im
landkreis esslingen
seither sind sie in quarantäne brauchen
jetzt zwei negative tests um wieder als
gesund zu gelten gliederschmerzen und
leichtes fieber hatten sie alles nicht
so wild bei ihnen und dennoch verstehen
sie dass eine schnelle corona
verbreitung verhindert werden muss
wir haben beide eltern großeltern die
wohnen zwar unter uns aber die meiden
wir weil für die ist es natürlich
gefährlich
die korona lage im ganzen land
beschäftigt auch hier alle
ich denke wenn man einigen nachmittagen
immer schlimmer
man macht sich schon gedanken ob es so
kommt wie in italien das wirklich das
ganze land mal irgendwann abgesperrt
wird aber dann ist es so an der
teststation bereiten sie inzwischen die
ersten röhrchen für den versand ins
labor vor innerhalb von zwei tagen
bekommen die getesteten dann bescheid ob
auch sie mit corona infiziert sind
wenn es positiv ist werden sie vom
gesundheitsamt informiert wenn es
negative ist wird das alles für uns auf
die dienststelle perfekten sind und
unsere mitarbeiter im büro telefonieren
alle leute durch rund 1400 menschen
haben sie hier allein in dieser woche
getestet die erste woche der mobilen
corona teststation in nürtingen
am montag geht es hier weiter dann mit
neuer schutzkleidung nach unseren
einsatz hier muss unsere schutzkleidung
jetzt entweder aufwendig desinfiziert
werden oder aber am besten direkt in den
müll einfach um ein weiteres risiko zu
verwandeln
professor plachta von der uni medizin
mainz ist virologe und heute unser gast
schön dass sie da sind
wann genau kann man den virus den
nachweisen wenn man den in sich trägt
also das passiert natürlich nicht ein
oder zwei tage macht wenn man kontakt
hat sondern es wahrscheinlich mindestens
drei tage wahrscheinlich eher vier oder
fünf tage dauern bis man wirklich diesen
erreger mit entsprechenden testen
nachweisen können und wann ist man
ansteckend ja das ist wahrscheinlich das
gleiche wahrscheinlich auch wiederum
drei vier tage fünf tage eben nach
infektion da muss man aber noch nicht
wirklich symptomatisch sein tatsächlich
natürlich ist hygiene wichtig das haben
jetzt auch schon wirklich oft gesagt
aber das gibt nochmal unterschiede
zwischen dem reinen desinfektionsmittel
und dem händewaschen ja eigentlich
reicht das händewaschen tatsächlich wenn
man ordentlich macht das heißt
mindestens 30 sekunden und auch wirklich
ordentlich die hände waschen dann
braucht man eigentlich kein
desinfektionsmittel und man muss sich
auch nicht unbedingt jetzt in der
apotheke laufen die desinfektionsmittel
sind wichtig für die krankenhäuser die
müssen entsprechende vorräte haben
da ist es viel sinnvoller tatsächlich
wirklich ordentlich daran zu halten wir
die hände zu waschen die hände waschen
genau ich habe gehört dass man da zum
beispiel eine strophe happy birthday
singen soll um die 30 sekunden
gibt es eine therapie wenn man den virus
denn dann hat im augenblick gibt es noch
keine zugelassene therapie aber es gibt
eben versuche zugelassene medikamente
die für andere viren eben bereits
getestet sind und zugelassen sind für
den menschen auch jetzt hier zu testen
ob sie wirksam sind da gibt es jetzt
verschiedene studien bei uns und auch in
anderen ländern um zu schauen ob daneben
bei schwerkranken patienten diese
medikamente auch was wirken
vielen dank professor plachta für ihren
besuch und ihre infos und unser corona
kompakt das finden sie auch bei youtube
und dort auf dem kanal der zdf heute da
können sie auch ihre fragen stellen alle
aktuellen informationen rund um das
corona virus bekommen sie jederzeit auch
auf heute.de im internet und natürlich
hier im programm